Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
Carrusel de las artes se encuentra en el
país Vasco francés para una semana de
cine y de culturas latinoamericanas en
el marco del festival biarritz América
Latina y el clima no ha sido demasiado
favorable esta semana sin embargo el
público del festival firmó presente para
esta edición 2022
[Música]
el festival biarritz América Latina
reúne a cineastas y artistas
latinoamericanos de primer orden en el
suroeste de Francia como siempre tres
competencias en largometrajes cortos y
documentales mayoría de mujeres
cineastas en Lisa por el abrazo a la
mejor película entre ellas la
costarricense Valentina maurel con su
cinta tengo sueños eléctricos Brasil su
cine su literatura y su música son El
plato fuerte de esta edición del
festival y en 31 años de existencia Qué
películas latinoamericanas han
deslumbrado al público es lo que
preguntamos por las calles de biarritz
[Música]
una semana de cine y de culturas
latinoamericanas Esa es la promesa que
hace cada año el festival biarritz
América Latina una semana en la que
vimos figuras destacadas desfilar por
biarritz el chileno Sebastián lelio
ganador del Oscar por una mujer
fantástica el venezolano Lorenzo vigas
premiado con el oso de oro en Venecia
por desde allá o el escritor cubano
Leonardo padura
[Aplausos]
todos se dieron cita en biarritz
Festival que como es tradición presenta
tres competencias cinematográficas en
largometrajes cortos y documentales y
nosotros tenemos cita ya mismo con el
nuevo delegado general del festival para
hablar de esta edición número 31
[Música]
Gracias por recibirnos en lagardi esta
es la sala de proyección principal del
festival biarritz América Latina y lo
decíamos antes muchas personalidades
este año en biarritz Después de tres
años complicados con el covid y todas
las restricciones que hemos tenido era
importante reunir aquí en biarritz a
todos sus directores escritores esos
creadores latinoamericanos sí es la
fiesta de la cultura latinoamericana de
manera global un poco más
específicamente del cine en
latinoamericano el festival en sí es una
declaración de amor a esos artistas Y
entonces que vengan para que se les
podamos decir les amamos llevo en
francés y ahora en la selección de este
año 10 películas que compiten por el
abrazo el premio más importante del
festival de biarritz háblenos de esas
películas y que nos cuentan de la
realidad es latinoamericanas es una
mezcla de género cinematográficos
queremos dar a sentir la diversidad de
la creación latinoamericana pero a
través de estas formas distintos vemos
aspectos diferentes a veces es muy
social a veces es por ejemplo tenemos
una comedia de acción Argentina donde
solamente la cosa es la obsesión para el
fútbol en Argentina lo cual es la pasión
tengo sueños eléctricos
un retrato muy delicado psicológico de
un adolescente en relación con su papá
que finalmente es más adolescente que
ella las tierras robadas en Colombia con
Los reyes del mundo hacia cosas del
íntimo más íntimo diversidad bueno
encontramos en esta selección países que
tienen una producción cinematográfica
consecuente Argentina México Colombia es
un país que está dando mucho cine pero
también otras
cinematografías que vemos quizás menos
Costa Rica y Nicaragua háblenos de esos
dos países que están presentes este año
Aquí
está presente con dos películas una
incompetencia una fuera de competencia
entonces tengo sueños eléctricos en
competencia y domingo y la niebla que
son dos películas muy distintas pero de
una madura es autoral muy impresionante
por un país que todavía está naciendo al
cine de una cierta manera y si hablamos
del Nicaragua creo que es la quinta
ficción producida largometraje de
ficción producido en este país es algo
muy muy importante a presentar Son obras
primas o segundas en el caso de Costa
Rica Son obras de jóvenes cineastas es
un lujo Yo creo de poder sentir el
continente en diferentes lugares con
diferentes sensibilidades y yo creo algo
que yo quisiera desta que es la
presencia de mujeres cineastas mujeres
que están haciendo cine en América
Latina
largometraje de ficción Son seis
cineastas sobre 10 seis mujeres y a la
vez tienen una mirada muy fuerte sobre
la mujer por ejemplo una película de de
género es era una reflexión sobre la
maternidad de una modernidad de una
precisión O sea la mujer a fuerza puede
ser feliz y lograda o no sé siendo mamá
no es la pregunta de la película y es
creo una pregunta que el mundo entero se
está cuestionando en este momento
histórico la película de Manuela Martell
y 1976 chilena buenísima como una mujer
burguesa tranquila se ve confrontada a
una realidad socio política que la
incomoda y me comprometo o no que qué
hago y tenemos El retrato de una niña
niña niña de adolescentes de etcétera O
sea sí realmente son miradas y
personajes femeninos muchísimas gracias
un delegado general del festival
biarritz América Latina y nosotros vamos
a seguir nuestra exploración de este
festival hablábamos hace un momento de
las mujeres cineastas y de países como
Costa Rica y justamente fuimos al
encuentro de una mujer cineasta
costarricense y está en la Competencia
por el premio el abrazo
Valentina maurel está en la competencia
en biarritz con su primer largometraje
tengo sueños eléctricos la cinta narra
la relación efusiva de Eva con su padre
un hombre imprevisible y violento del
que ha heredado una rabia que la
consumimos
quería hablar sobre todo en el
adolescencia y fue escribiendo Como que
surgió este tema de la violencia también
quería hablar de la violencia que
circula en una familia y que se
transmite de la dimensión un poco
nefasta de una herencia
en el papel de Eva la joven Daniela
Marín Navarro galardonada en el festival
de San Sebastián por este papel en
realidad es una experiencia que todas
las personas tenemos ahí y a pesar de
que no es claramente el personaje no soy
yo ni uno sabe ciertas cosas porque las
a también vivido de cierta forma yo
quería construir el personaje de manera
que también se pueda lograr notar todos
estos tipos de matices que tenía también
hacer que no Simplemente estuviera
siempre en un mismo lugar sino que
también el personaje evoluciona a través
de la película
[Música]
después
Valentina maurel es Franco costarricense
y asegura que Costa Rica es un vivero de
historias también una cosa de la
identidad que es compleja y yo creo que
por eso quería hacer mis películas allá
como que siento que yo nací crecía en
Costa Rica Y entonces regresada ya me
permite pues intentar encontrar el
origen de lo que soy como
centroamericano no siempre está mirando
hacia el exterior hacia Europa hacia los
Estados Unidos y ya es hora de que
alguien pues firme las calles de San
José Las playas también pero a mí me
parece también que la urbanidad verdad
Para que nos demos cuenta que si hay
historias que contar si hay cosas
interesantes que decir yo le dije no
estoy enamorado el festival biarritz
América Latina celebra por todo lo alto
Brasil en el marco del Bicentenario de
su independencia y de unas elecciones
presidenciales cruciales el público del
festival podrá descubrir una selección
de películas brasileñas escogidas por
uno de los cineastas más destacados del
momento clever Mendoza Filio y de todo
esto nos habló nadie Solano una de las
responsables del festival
[Música]
por favor para componer este Focus le
dimos una invitación al Gran cineasta
clever Mendoza filo que muy amablemente
nos hizo una propuesta increíble de
variadas cinematografías brasileras
incluso lo dice el mismo clever que él
propone un álbum de familia muy
incompleto porque el cine brasilero la
cinematografía es tan extensa que no se
puede presentar en tan pocas solo 14
películas desde globe Rocha a Eduardo cu
también Héctor barbenco como películas
clásicas que realmente marcaron la
cinematografía y películas del nordeste
de minas yeray películas de mujeres de
los jóvenes cineastas ahora que están
con una mirada muy interesante sobre la
situación actual y es cierto que es
importante también para nosotros en este
momento darles espacio al cine brasilero
ver cómo ese cine brasilero esa cultura
brasilera está presente sigue muy fuerte
está viva
[Música]
el festival de biarritz cuenta con un
público fiel Que firma presente en las
salas de cine así que nosotros quisimos
saber qué películas han gustado más en
estos 31 años de festival es un
reportaje de Melissa barra por las
calles de biarritz
por las salas del festival de biarritz
han pasado grandes obras del cine
latinoamericano cintas memorables que
sus habituales nunca olvidarán
me acuerdo de regreso a ítaca de luego
encanté hablaba de las decepciones de
cubanos que se habían ido de La Isla el
guión era de Leonardo padura yo me quedé
y afronté las cosas recuerda haber
pensado Cómo logra vivir en Cuba sin
sufrir la represión
[Música]
Colombia pájaros de verano una película
colombiana sobre cómo nacen los carteles
de la droga Me gustó muchísimo el
autismo que la película destaca de ese
país de sufríe
en La dictadura perfecta Mr envasador
éxitos
México que trata de del Antiguo
presidente mexicano y cómo se sirvió de
los medios de comunicación para ser
presidente muy real y con mucho humor un
abrazo de la serpiente
[Música]
trata de la naturaleza en una amazonas
como llegan los investigadores que
vienen a buscar algo en la tierra y se
encuentran confrontados a la mentalidad
de los indios que es muy bella
nunca he soñado y dormido y despierto No
saltases es una película con Ricardo
darín
[Música]
es una película muy fantástica para mí
son pequeños escenas y son
ahora
[Música]
qué violencia
Gracias Melissa Barry con esto ponemos
Punto Final Este programa especial que
les presentamos desde el festival
biarritz América Latina y los dejamos
con uno de los grupos que estuvo
presentes en esta semana de cine y de
culturas latinoamericanas
[Música]
tu corazón
estoy muy feliz cuando bate en mi
corazón 4 con cada serie
[Música]
[Aplausos]